hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my arrow episode 2 video we
finally got to meet the Ragman character
so just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet so we
meet new team arrow we have Artemis
we have Ragman now I'll talk about
Ragman especially because I felt like he
probably had the best arc in the episode
as it applies to putting the new team
together there was some nice symmetry
between his character Oliver's character
their father sacrificing themselves to
protect them as well as like symmetry
with the flashbacks the narrative
structure of the episode was great and
for those of you that are still thinking
that Tommy might be prometheus there
were a couple moments in the episode
that I felt like provided some evidence
for that but it's still kind of up in
the air the way they're flanges voice
like the way they're modulating his
voice makes it sound like it could be a
man or a woman they just want to be as
ambiguous as possible about it but I
think it all goes back to the idea of
Oliver doing all the wrong things up to
this moment you know like that speech
that he has with Ragman I don't want to
fail anymore so the thing that he does
to not fail anymore with the new team is
to reveal his identity so we'll say like
number 10
Prometheus theory like this just cast
some more evidence for Tommy but I don't
necessarily think that it's Tommy but I
do think that it's fun to talk about
Oliver trusting people or not trusting
people failing in season one you know up
to this point so pretty much all the
seasons up to now maybe if he had
trusted Tommy and revealed his identity
to him he would not have died during
season 1 so number 9 prometheus reveals
himself to Tobias Church you almost
killed him he's mine I had the right to
kill him I think this is the first time
we've heard them speak their name out
loud so Prometheus still very mysterious
but probably slowly trying to make
Oliver pay for all those mistakes that
he himself said that he had been making
this whole time I've been failing this
whole time just remember it all comes
back to that a lot of the problems that
Oliver has this season will be a direct
result of decisions mistakes that he
made in previous seasons Prometheus
being the most personal one so like it
sounds like Prometheus will be somebody
that he failed either through the
actions like the list somebody that he
killed someone's family if it's going to
be a
comic book II twist or they could make
it really personal but just Prometheus
the idea of like the modern Prometheus
you know like Frankenstein somebody that
was resurrected via science or the idea
of the Greek Prometheus the person who
stole fire from the God like tricked the
gods in order to help man and who were
the gods of the aro universe if not the
green arrow the flash like the other
members of the Justice Society but we
need a little more context to kind of
narrow down the choices in terms of who
Prometheus could be number eight though
failing a big theme of the episode
Quentin totally epic fail on the job so
Quentin isn't like after-school special
mode he's doing his best
Oliver impression from before the
Queen's Gambit like the douchebag
version of Oliver just drunk all the
time just a complete mess so of course
the offer send the job of deputy mayor I
guess she's trying to give him a reason
to be sober like his reason to be sober
before was his family he doesn't have
them anymore because one of them is dead
the other ones lost in time so Thea is
like trying to do the right thing so he
is actually doing a really good thing
even if it did feel like an after-school
special I didn't like the scene but I do
like what they're doing with the
character number seven Oliver puts that
new team together
ring that Bell just a great montage of
him kicking the [ __ ] out of them you get
a Robin Hood joke nice word play with
him sticking Roy and Barry with arrows
as he was trying to train them and
symmetry with the flashbacks with him
having to ring the bell with the Bratva
so number six is the way the Brava
flashbacks totally [ __ ] on the ideology
of new team arrow in trusting people
like the way it was edited was great too
because you go from Oliver like trusting
people and it working really great in
present-day
to immediate flashbacks whereby like he
rings the bell and all the people that
help him get shot down so just yanking
the rug right out from under him number
five intro to Ragman I was so happy they
went comic-book Ragman with this now
they're like a few changes so in the
comics rag man's cloak is made from the
tatters of the villains whose souls he's
absorbed so like when he defeats someone
like when you see him sticking the rags
down people's throats suffocating them
on the TV show that's kind of like the
TV shows version of the cloak in the
comics absorbing their souls so they did
tone it down just a little
it but the cloak itself is a magical
item like to say it's 2,000 years old
and it's radioactive because of the
explosions at Haven rock which we
learned is where Ragman is from but like
in the comics Ragman is a slightly more
mystical character so he'd be like a
prime candidate for a Constantine
crossover so they might save some Ragman
stuff for the next time Constantine
shows up like that 2000 years old thing
like the way he explains it to Oliver it
sounds like he doesn't fully understand
the history of the cloak he just knows
that it's very old it's like a family
heirloom that's been passed down so that
be something that you would let
Constantine explain to him but as far as
I know there is no Constantine
appearance that scheduled this season
but they did say that they're going to
bring him back as soon as possible not
just on arrow but like on legends of
tomorrow the other DC shows so number
four is actually like the felicity plot
that you probably picked up on during
the episode where he's narrating his
backstory I was at Haven Rock I'm going
after the people responsible for the
nukes which is the Ameritech company and
then probably once he finds out that
felicity is the one that diverted that
missile that blew up his home there'll
be all kinds of drama between them too
but aside from people getting really
excited at the thought of him choking
Felicity out I don't think that anything
is really gonna come of it I mean one of
the big ideas of being a hero is
learning about forgiveness so of course
he's not going to kill felicity is
revenge for his family dying in the
meantime though felicity is gonna feel
super guilty about Haven rock like they
tease that that's where Felicity's story
is going to flow from the first part of
the season just you know dealing with
the emotional fallout as well as you
know maybe something like the literal
radioactive fallout from Haven rock but
nice parody with Nero number three
diggle's storyline where his military
team tries to frame him stealing one of
the genesis devices so you kind of see
how Diggle is going to make his way back
to team arrow eventually like he'll have
to come back either because he's
court-martialed or just because he wants
to get away from that bad situation so
they did a really good job of like
weaving together the idea of putting new
teams together the right way the wrong
way like in the flashbacks
and then kind of subverting that with
Diggle storyline being like you know
sometimes you can't trust your team but
my number-two favorite moment was
probably the clinic scene where Oliver
was there as the mayor and the Green
Arrow kind of trying to play both sides
like the people there the Ameritech
people as mayor Queen and protect them
as the green arrow without really
revealing anything to his team so
there's just like a lot of funny
wordplay like a scene within a scene so
it's a training moment for the team but
it's also like a big mayor queen moment
they've really been downplaying the
mayoral storyline too so I feel like
that's going to come to a head like
Oliver trying to double time training
the team as well as running the city is
just going to go horribly for him but
number one moment I'd say probably all
the Ragman takedowns I feel like they
did a good job with the effects the
conception of the character is good like
it's going to be a meaningful thing for
the other characters on the team just
because they tied it back to Haven rock
and they weaved in a really awesome
mythological element with the
two-thousand-year-old cloak that has a
mind of its own so I tend to like
characters like that just a little bit
more like when they have this implied
history even if they don't totally
understand it so let me know what was
your guys favorite moment from the
episode what do you think about the
Ragman character and how do you like how
do you like the way they're weaving the
flashbacks in with the present-day
scenes I feel like it works so much
better this season so just a reminder
though next week Stephen Amell vs Cody
Rhodes rematch payback is a [ __ ] so
what's going to happen next is I'm going
to do an Aquaman mera video they just
revealed what Mira's costume is going to
look like in the Justice League movie
and in the Aquaman movie so be sure to
subscribe to get that in legends of
tomorrow Justice Society episode 1 drops
tomorrow so I'll be posting that after
it airs they're introducing a whole
bunch of new characters they've
completely torn the show apart and
rebuilt it so it's not gonna look
anything like it did during season 1
which I feel like was a bit of a mess so
Justice Society dropping Thursday night
will you guys wait for them to post you
can click here for my flash dr. alchemy
video and you can click here for my
Supergirl metallo trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight